are we going to get rid of these kids
having to
stay home if one person in the class
tests positive
well we have as your reporter says we
are conducting
trials of daily contact testing as a
possible
alternative to self-isolation what
matters also is that we keep the school
safe and if you go around our schools
you will see
a raft of measures to reduce the
infection rates within schools so
there's
extra hygiene there's staggered breaks
we keep children in bubbles
and there's extra ventilation in in
classrooms too to minimize the risk of
transmission
there are about three percent of uh
students are
self-isolating at the moment um and
that's lower than it was
in the autumn and and it tends to
correlate within
the number of infections in the
community but you know children are
testing at home twice a week it's very
important that families continue to
test their children uh twice a week so
we can identify children who do have
covid
and then they don't come into the school
and spread that that virus
to other children so is that a yes
no we'll look at the results of the
trial and we'll make any decisions we'll
be announced before
we make a decision on step four going
forward but
you know we have to do everything we can
to minimize the risk of transmission
of this virus and that's why all those
measures have been taken within schools
to keep to keep children and staff safe
so we'll know by the 19th of july
yes we will and we've also written to
schools
uh yesterday asking to prepare for
two tests to take place on the school
premises as a way of preparing for that
when we come back in september what
we're also concerned about is having
more children in school we want children
to be in school that's why schools
opened on the 8th of march it's why
we prioritize education so the schools
will be last to close first to open
as we deal with this dreadful virus and
this pandemic
because we do know that children are
better for their well-being for their
uh for their health for their education
by being in schools and again that's why
we have the twice weekly testing and
it's why we have all the raft of
control measures within the school
premises to minimize the risk of
transmission of the virus
um yeah it's not working though is it 93
000 young people have failed to return
to full-time
education after schools reopen their
doors um
what are you going to do about that well
this is an issue that's always worried
us
um that's about 30 000 more than you see
in a normal non-pandemic
year these are vulnerable children we
want them in school
when the lockdown occurred in march we
took extra measures to
get schools to talk to the parents of of
those disengaged
children who were not coming into school
schools remained open of course if you
remember for
vulnerable children and the children of
critical workers where we weren't seeing
those families sending their children
into school
uh the school would contact the families
we would work with our regional teams
uh local authority level to again to
talk to those families via
via social workers and so on to help do
everything we can to
encourage those children to to come into
school
perhaps extending the school day by half
an hour is that going to happen from
september
well catch up of course is very
important even as early as
june last year uh the prime minister
announced a billion pounds of funding
for catch up for money to schools to
spend as they felt
appropriate to help children to catch up
also the national tutoring program was
introduced
uh back in june last year um and
we've uh earlier in june we announced
another 1.4 billion bringing the total
together with a february announcement up
to over three billion pounds of catch up
uh and that includes money also to help
uh
to to for teachers to do the to be the
best that they can through extra
cpd and training because we know that
the best catch-up of course k happens
every day in school with children at
school in those classrooms
um but we're also conducting a review uh
right now of the evidence about
extending the school day and
time spent in school to understand how
that would work
how effective it would be uh to if we
were to increase the
the length of the school day okay the
other thing you're looking at is mobile
free
school days i mean schools already have
very robust policies
in place when it comes to the use of
mobiles
they know what they're doing don't they
a number of schools increasing number of
schools are
banning mobile phones from the school
day keeping them out of the classrooms
they are a distraction there is
evidence that that they improve
entertainment particularly
uh children of the you know less
academic children
do better if they're not distracted by
mobile phones countries like france
banned
mobile phones from schools two or three
years ago
and i've always been in favor of banning
mobile phones from the classroom they
also can affect children's
mental health and their well-being
they're continually spending you know
too much time
on the screen in our uh
curriculum on relationship and health
education
uh we you know we ask teachers to teach
children
the importance of rationing the use of
mobile phones so they are spending time
outside with friends doing their
homework talking to their parents and
not always glued
to their mobile phone so yes we we do
want to to ban
mobile phones from the classroom but we
are today
launching a call for evidence to see how
best to implement such a policy
and also other measures we want to take
to ensure that we eliminate
low-level disruption in our classroom
get rid of bullying in our classrooms we
want children to have a happy
safe time at school and building on the
work we've
conducted over the last 10 years to give
teachers more
power more control over the classroom
this is going a step further now to make
sure that every classroom is safe
and a happy place you know the teachers
unions have said that they already do
that so they're not quite sure why
you're
why you're saying that this morning
something that else that you had
said that people that pupils don't need
from the 17th of may was masks
in schools and as a result we've seen
the number of kids that have tested
positive
going up and up and up will you look at
that again come september will kids have
to potentially wear masks when they go
back to school
well first of all increasing uh
numbers of children who are isolating
the three percent dimension earlier
is driven mainly by infection rates in
the community there's a correlation
between
the number of children who are asked to
self-isolate because they've come into
contact with somebody who've covered
and the degree of infection in the the
community
we introduced the face coverings for
pupils in secondary school classrooms
uh as a temporary measure we reviewed
that over easter
and from may the 17th it's no longer a
recommendation but of course
we do give discretion to directors of
public health around the country
particularly in areas of high infection
rates
to re to reintroduce or to maintain that
recommendation
uh in classrooms and i think in about 60
local authorities
in those high infection rates around the
country that there are recommendations
to continue
uh face coverings in in classrooms but
it was a temporary measure
uh and as i said the the the issue isn't
about infections
within the school of a huge raft of
measures in place so hygiene ventilation
cycle breaks and so on
to limit the risk of transmission in
schools
this is about transmission in the
community um will you be wearing a mask
after the 19th of july
indoors well i i wear a mask
uh now when uh when when necessary
and that's the law yes and i will um
we'll see what is announced uh as we
move to step four
well i spoke to several of your
colleagues over the last couple of weeks
including george eustis he says he's not
going to wear a mask after the 19th of
july and as you know the chancellor's
also said the same i just wondered what
your view was
my view is that i will adhere to
whatever the guidance is that's
announced
leading up to step four the roadmap so
even if it's not
a regulation that you need to wear a
mask you might still wear one
i will wear whatever the recommendations
are the guidances to
to individuals about when and whether
they should wear a face mask
we all have to do everything we can to
to minimize the risk of
transmission and but
you know we want the roadmap to be a
one-way journey
we want it to be irreversible and we
will look at the data
and i'm optimistic the way things
looking at the moment that
the 19th of july will be the step
forward the roadmap
okay um have you seen the video chris
witty i'm sure you have um
being um assaulted by some
jobs last night what do you think should
happen to them
and do you think that he should have
some form of protection because he
obviously
is dividing opinion this is the the
videos we're talking to you what do you
think
i think this scene is absolutely
appalling
and i'm sure all your viewers and the
general public
will absolutely condemn the behavior of
these jobs
chris whittie has done a fantastic job
throughout the pandemic in advising the
government of the necessary measures
to keep uh our nhs uh
safe to save lives and he has you know
been a very effective uh
chief medical officer during that that
period and those scenes should not have
happened this is now a matter of police
investigation
and i hope the whole weight of the law
will will come down on
on people that engage in that kind of
behavior
should he uh be afforded some sort of
close protection
well that is a matter for uh for the
security services and
plan for chris whitty but those scenes
should never have occurred in our
society
absolutely wrong people whatever role
they have in government should be able
to
walk on the street walk through the park
unaccosted by
that kind of behavior it should not
happen in a in a free law abiding
society like ours
have you ever used um a private email
account for government business
all business that i conduct goes through
my
private office the information
commissioner
is clear that any key actions and
decisions are
recorded and that's why all government
action that i
conduct takes place through my private
office how i communicate with my private
office
uh is is through a range of measures
including mostly paper through the
through the red box system
so you've never used a private email
account to carry out government business
well i will talk to my private office
through a range of measures you know
phone text
email but the business government
business is conducted
via the private office so that there is
a record of all
key actions and decisions that are taken
uh
all government action you know all
government business takes place through
that office
um how surprised are you that other
ministers
um are not as fastidious as you when it
comes to
carrying out government business well i
think all misses do
they conduct business through their
private office it's it's
it's how you know
i'm sorry talking about private email
accounts as you know and
as we know uh at least two uh ministers
in the department of health have used
their private email accounts
well that's a matter for the department
of health and to
see what your opinion is well the rules
are very clear that
all government action needs to take
place through private offices through
through formal channels so that a record
can be kept of those key
decisions and when there are probably
people do of course have private
conversations
uh and the key thing is that those
private conversations are
communicated to the private office so
that they can then be
if if necessary recorded as part of the
decision making process
do you have a cctv camera in your office
yes
no i don't uh i did ask the question of
course i bet you did
i bet you did um you saw chris bryant
yesterday saying that matt hancock is
the stupidest man on earth um snogging
his mistress in front of a cctv camera
it wasn't the smartest thing to do was
it
well matt hancock has said that he
uh breached the social distancing rules
and as a consequence he felt
that he was head to his island and
that's what happened on
saturday matt hancock has been i think a
very
good uh health secretary he has managed
this
crisis i think the pandemic crisis
exemplary
and we have kept the nhs safe it hasn't
been overwhelmed in that period
and we have them one of the most
successful vaccination rollouts
in the world with 85 percent of adults
now
having had at least one dose and 60
percent of adults having had
two doses so uh i would pay tribute to
matt he
took what he felt was the right decision
to resign
and that decision was accepted by the
prime minister
he also employed his mistress at our
expense
well uh you know i'm a education
minister
uh to be appointed a non-executive
director
there is a process that's uh gone
through with
an appoints appointment commission
commissioner involved i'm sure that that
was the process that happened in the
department of health but i'm not close
enough
to all the details no but she's his
mistress
and we were paying her well
what you want from a non-executive
director is their expertise and
experience
and that's what will have been sought in
the department of health but again i'm
not
close enough to to the process to to
know all the details
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
thank you